the race for the Republican Presidential
nomination is a long way to go but the
top two candidates are already trying to
make it a one-on-one contest former
president Donald Trump and Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis are telling voters
the other Contender is the wrong choice
and O'Keefe is in Des Moines Iowa Ed
good morning
glad happy Friday to you you're right
the Trump and DeSantis campaign sure are
trying to set the Two Front Runners
apart from the rest of the pack the
former president was here in Iowa
yesterday talking to voters appearing
last night on Fox News while Governor
DeSantis was up in New Hampshire he's in
South Carolina today making his case
one-time friends
now bitter opponents Iran as I call him
Rhonda sanctimonious for a reason former
president Donald Trump continues to lead
the GOP field and he's doing what he can
to keep Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
from Catching him
this week DeSantis has launched his bid
by vowing to completely remake
Washington over the course of two
consecutive terms while Trump would be
limited to one we will work incredibly
hard day after day for two terms over
eight year period to deliver results
I've been watching to Sanctus go out and
say uh I've got eight years it's going
to be eight years let me tell you
something right there you should vote
against him it'll take me six months to
have it totally the way it was asked
about what Trump said to santis
responding anyone that tells you oh I'll
take care of it'll be done in one day or
six months
um you know they're selling you a bill
of goods the governor has mostly focused
on taking on President Biden on Thursday
in New Hampshire he criticized the
president for pushing the Democratic
party to drop New Hampshire as its first
primary State he's doing that for his
own interest that's not the interest of
our Republic
the tradition that's worked very well so
I'm happy to be participating in this
and I'm glad the Republicans are getting
are going to keep it on the calendar and
what does DeSantis make of Trump's
attacks I don't think that's what voters
want and honestly I think that that his
conduct uh which he's been doing for
years now I think that's one of the
reasons he's not in the white house now
because I think he alienated too many
voters but on his second official day of
campaigning DeSantis got noticeably
irritated what a reporter wondered why
he's yet to take questions from voters
I'm out here working with people are you
[Music]
he had a very bad day today got very
angry at the Press
you're not allowed to get angry at the
Press
as for President Biden at age 80 his age
continues to be a concern for voters and
this scene didn't help he was shaking
hands on stage at the Air Force
Commencement Address Thursday when he
tripped on a sandbag he was quickly held
to his feet by Air Force personnel in
the Secret Service the White House later
clarified he tripped over the sandbag he
wasn't injured and the president himself
joked about it when he got home to the
White House saying he got quote sandback
Errol well Macy's making a joke about it
yeah but I can see those Republican
attack ads being edited as we speak
thank you very much but Ed before you go
couldn't anybody have honestly couldn't
anybody have tripped over a sandbag you
could have done it I could have done it
sure
sure but they're not an 80 year old
president the oldest that's ever served
amid concerns from voters that somebody
that old may not be able to serve as
president
okay all right we'll see that's a good
point and he doesn't like questions
about his physical life no he doesn't he
take it from me but he didn't see a
narrative
um coming up all right Ed thank you for
that